正統派です
暑い!
暑くて何も、、、暑くて何もしたくないんですけども、この暑い中でも唯一俺がしたい事がある
それは何か?  そう!!
ベイブレード。
これ、扇風機代わりに、ならない。
と言う訳でベイブレードなんですけども。
ボクは思ったわけですよ
普通のスタジアムで戦っても、ﾁｮﾁｮﾁｮﾁｮ siiiiii  静かに
普通のスタジアムで戦うのも十分楽しいんですけども
特殊なステージでちょっと戦わせてみたいと思ったんですよ!
この子たちもそれを望んでる。
ああぁ
もっと特殊なスタジアムで試合はできないかとボクは思ったわけなんですよ
私は思った！もしこのスタジアムが全部凍っていたら、果たしてこいつらはどの様に戦うか
タダですらこんな早いのに、このスタジアムの中を氷漬けにしたら果たしてベイブレードは
ベイブレードはどの様に戦うのかって事を僕、疑問に思ったわけデアス
多分このままこのスタジアムに水を入れても、
水が溜まっちゃって、くぼんでいるココだけが多分氷になっちゃって、
均等に氷のスタジアムは出来ないと思った訳であります。
そこでわたくし何を使うと言いますと
こちら!
こ!ﾀﾞｯｼｬ　待った、全体的にﾔﾊﾞいすよそれは
こちら！ローション。
髪型に慣れねぇな
ローションはへばり付くので
スタジアム全体がこう均等にローションで
水まみれになる、ヌルヌルにね
で、結局ローションもね凍らせれば氷になるんで
均等に氷の皮膜を張った
スケートリンク場になったスタジアムで
ベイブレードを回すと果たしてどのようになるのか
っていうのが僕気になりました
よし、ちょっと軽～くのせました
どれくらいの量ならいいのかな？
あ、もうこれでも結構のびるなー
わ、す、、、わー、わー
割りといいかもね、これ。
非常に伝わりにくいと思いますが
結構均等に伸びております。
いやでももう十分じゃない？
一回ローションでも回してみよう！！
一回ローションで回したらどうなるかやってみましょう。
こいつさっきまであの動きしてたやつですからね。
変わるな、プレーイングが
ゴムグリップだから、その摩擦がなくなったからか！
このローションをもっときれいに広げよう
あぁ今いい具合だと思います。
これくらいの感じで行きましょう
では、スタジアムを冷やしてきます。
あれ、おいおいおい
えー
結構でかいんだね、スタジアムって。
しばしお待ちを
おー！！おおおおおおおお　ヤバいヤバい！！
冷凍スタジアムです！！
これが冷凍スタジアムです。
まって、溶ける溶ける溶ける　溶ける溶ける
早く！！　今の日本は暑いからな
はい、というわけでもう完全に　氷でございます。
もうもう　これはもう回すしかないよ
ヴァルキリー行くぞ！！
３，２，１ゴーシュ！！
よくわかりません。
もう戦わせてみましょう。
もう戦わせよう。
オッシャー！！
そこで止まる！？
うぉー、びっくり！！
今の場所は止まる場所ではなかったぞ
あ、痛たたたた！！
そういう動画じゃありません。
ゴーシュ！！
基本的にはあんま変わんないな
飛びやすくなってる？！
普通より飛びますなー、なんか
ううわっ
めちゃくちゃ威力が強いです！！
めちゃくちゃぶつかると飛びます。
摩擦が少ないから、ぶつかるとすっごいはねます。
いや！すげーこれ！！
だからそういう動画じゃないって